but last night perfectly clear skies and
you can see i can see the man in the
moon john you see him
there that's where we left
it is beautiful and that's off to the
spring mountains to the west
the sun is rising in the east right now
and temperatures are kind of cool
we're down to 37 in seven hills 37 at
nellis
aliante you're at 40. summerlin at 43
same for the lakes mountains edge close
to 30s 33 in front
and 35 in mesquite all along the
colorado river today
and out at lake mead we're going to look
for some bumpy northerly breezes
shouldn't hurt your golf game though
here in the valley unless maybe you're
out at lake las vegas you might get in
on a little bit of that wind
or closer to the lake if you plan on
being out on the boat just please watch
it maybe two to three
foot waves today but for the valley
we're looking at 53 by 9 a.m
60 by noon and mid 60s for the afternoon
high beautiful nice and clear
all those high clouds yesterday they
thinned out by noon
that wind advisory now has been issued
by the national weather service it
starts at 9 a.m this morning
for all these areas in blue until 5 pm
this afternoon
it will get a little windier for the
valley later in the week by thursday as
a secondary system
drops into the middle of the country and
it's going to spread some cooler
air from the middle of the u.s over to
the desert southwest we'll go from 65
today
to 57 by thursday so that's our little
dip and then by the weekend
we'll get right back to some 60s but
look at those morning lows in the mid
30s
that's why i remind you to make sure
you're watering setting your sprinklers
for daytime hours not overnight